all right this is from usa today it says
paypal is collaborating with the
anti-defamation league on research aimed
at cutting off funding for extremist or
hate groups
in a statement monday adl said the
research will explore how extremist or
hate movements use financial platforms
to fund their activities
both that organization and paypal say
the results of their research will be
shared within the financial industry
also policymakers and law enforcement
the chief risk officer and executive
vice president of risk and
platforms at paypal said in a statement
by identifying partners across sectors
with common goals and complementary
resources
we can make an even greater impact than
any of us would ever do on our own
as part of the initiative paypal and adl
adl will also form a coalition with
civil rights organizations
to protect marginalized communities from
extremism
adlc ceo jonathan greenblatt said
we have a unique opportunity to further
understand how hate spreads and develop
key insights that will inform
the efforts of the financial industry
law enforcement and our communities
in mitigating extremist threats
so that's the story here's a relevant
part of the adl state
statement on this new initiative it says
the initiative with paypal
will be led through adl's center on
extremism a leading authority on
extremism terrorism and hate
paypal and adl will focus on further
uncovering and disrupting
the financial pipelines that support
extremist and hate movements
in addition to extremist and
anti-government organizations the
initiative will focus on actors and
networks spreading and profiting
from all forms of hate and bigotry
against any community
this is a financial institution teaming
up with uh
anti-defamation league which is really
just a left-wing advocacy group
in order to target hate and extremism
nothing to worry about there right
of course there's a lot to worry about
and this was guaranteed now
we should have been worried about this
you know back when concepts like hate
speech
took hold
or even using a word like extremism or
an extremist as if it's an objectively
bad label
you know that's to be extreme in your
views
whether or not that's a bad thing it
really depends on what the view is
if you're if you're correct
um if you are in truth
then there's there's no way to be too
extreme there's no way to be too extreme
about the truth
extremism becomes a problem extremism is
a problem of degree
if you're wrong and you're
you know and you're extremely wrong then
that's going to be even worse than
than being sort of moderately wrong
so all of these were extreme radical oh
we wouldn't want to have radicals it's
bad thing to be a radical well
it really depends doesn't it depends on
what your cause is
what your movement is
fundamentalist is another word related
to that
it's a bad thing to be a fundamentalist
talking about religious people
yeah it's bad to be a fundamentalist if
the fundamentals of your religion
are flawed but if they're not
then yeah you ought to be a
fundamentalist just means abiding by the
fundamentals
of your religion if the fundamentals of
your religion are violent
then yes it's a problem to be a
fundamentalist there
so it really depends and that's also the
case with hate
is it a bad thing to hate
again it depends it depends on what you
hate
and why everybody hates things
it's part of being a human being hate is
the other
is is the the other side of the coin to
love they're on the same coin
in fact in order to love something you
must also
hate example
um i love my children more than life
itself
and because i love them there are many
things that i therefore hate
primarily anything that threatens to
hurt them and cause them harm
anything that that wishes to corrupt
them
you know i hate that
it's a big reason why i hate um
left-wing gender theory critical race
theory
because of of the harm that it does to
kids who are indoctrinated into it
but we have as a society including a lot
of conservatives we've gone along with
this
idea that uh all hate is automatically
bad
hey you don't want to get engage in hate
speech is like a different category from
regular speech
see there's regular speech which is okay
and that's when you're giving your
opinions about things
but uh hate speech is a totally
different thing and that's bad
because it means that you're using
speech to convey that you hate something
well it's only bad it's only bad
sometimes
depends on what you're hating right
it's extremism there's a radical
fundamentalist
we allowed all of these words to become
uh objectively bad
in our culture and now
and now this and now there's a by the
most powerful forces in our culture
on a campaign to erase hate and
extremism
and on the surface level who could
possibly object they just want to get
rid of hate hate's a bad thing right
hate speech is different than regular
speech we've already apparently we've
all agreed with this and established it
but because it all depends now it's
going to be a matter of the question is
well well
okay uh what
what type of hate are you going after
here
are you going to be targeting people
what about those who would hate someone
like me
being a white conservative male what
about that kind of hate speech
oh no we're going to leave that alone
because that's the good hate
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated